[Music]
welcome everyone over the next like
that's the official type talk of the
title I didn't bother to write that on
the piece of paper but welcome everyone
I would like to give you over the next
thirty minutes as I said a brief
introduction of like web security and
things that I believe are important for
every web developer no matter whether
you're responsible for security or not
because in my opinion everyone is
responsible for security and not just
the person who has it in their title and
hopefully by the end of the talk
all of these abbreviations gonna make it
a little bit more sense to you but
before we start I would like to
introduce myself so I'm Dominic I live
in Berlin and I work as a weapon as a
developer evangelist for a company
called Twilio we were the ones who put
out the t-shirts if you manage to grab
one and we have we're an API company
that has api's around communications
such as SMS voice video or chat as well
as things like two-factor authentication
but there's one more thing that you
should know about me and I you might
have gotten the hint by me running
around like this I'm part of a group
called one zjs we're just a bunch of
lovely people that you're more than
welcome to come up to and chat with us
that's the first time we have pulled
this off back at row J's which is an
amazing conference organized by Matt
Lane walking over there and now running
away it's a social network for web web
developers who are developers in general
who love onesies and you know being a
developer I obviously made sure that
this is a secure as possible so that
people with bananas come hacker if you
see the banana trying to hack their you
know and I thought of everything so it
uses HTTP and thanks for let's encrypt
there's really no excuse to not using
HTTPS because you can do it for free it
uses HSTs
which is the HTTP strict Transport
protocol which is the thing that makes
sure that you can't go to Google when
you're on an open network that is trying
to redirect you to a captive portal
basically what it makes sure is that
there
no down rate in your connection when you
are from HTTP to HTTPS no mixed content
meaning there's no HTTP content on my
https website
I'm sanitizing the input because as the
social networks obviously you can post
things in my case with markdown and I'm
sanitizing that input and there's no
room for sequel injections because if
you are not using a real database there
are no real sequel injections and I'm
not talking about no sequel databases
because there are no sequel injections
as well but I'm really just using a
plain storage so there's no room for me
to have like any sequel injections or no
sequel injections turns out though that
developing secure web applications isn't
as easy as I thought so I asked my buddy
Bob Ellison to kind of like take a stab
at the application and they found a
bunch of vulnerabilities that I wanted
to share with you and with that let's
actually take a look at the site now you
can actually see it so this is how the
fluffiest social network and the work
looks like I'm gonna switch to cloning
so I can all right so if we go here
that's the login portal and I'm gonna
open the dev tools here and go to the
network tab just so we can see what's
actually happening on the side and I'm
gonna log in here with my super secure
password and what we're doing is we're
doing a normal post request and we're
signing a auth token here which is what
is called a jar to jason JWT or a JSON
web token and if I go to okay installed
a small helper tool here to let me work
better with you tokens but if you never
saw how a JSON web token looked like
there's a nice tool called JWT IO where
we can inspect this and basically a JSON
web token has three different sections
so it has a it has a header which
defines hey this is actually a judge and
then it has an algorithm which is used
to generate a signature which is the
last part of it and then in the middle
we have a payload and this payload you
can have
arbitrary data now the header and the
payload you should be aware are not in
like encrypted they're simply base64
encoded so you should never have like
sensible data in there anyway it's like
there shouldn't be a password in there
please don't put a password in there but
like to make sure that this can't be
like temporary with we actually have a
signature in our case we can see the
signature right now it's invalid because
I'm trying to verify it verified against
a secret called secret and I was smart
enough to not use that as my secret now
the thing is if you if you look at the
spec of jobs there's a bunch of
algorithms that this should support and
one of them is called none which you as
you can see the signature disappears
because we're just simply not generating
a signature and this is sort of meant to
be for you know like non sensitive data
if you just want to try to transmit data
in like a standardized format the thing
though is that we can we can try and see
if my library is weak enough to fail
with this so we switch the role to admin
and just submit this and if we refresh
the page now let's see if you notice any
changes we're now able to authenticate
as an admin in fact we wouldn't have had
to login in the first place we could
have just generated this token um
because I'm verifying this token and
then take that as a source of truth on
my website which is what most websites
actually do and that's as you can see
not great because like we could log in
as any music so how can we protect
ourselves from that the first thing you
should do is you should really use HTTP
only cookies if you're if there's no
reason for it to be accessible in
JavaScript and in this case the
authentication token there is really no
use for it to be access accessible
JavaScript you should also make sure
that it's signed meaning it's signed
with a secret so that nobody else can
temper with it and it's secure meaning
it's only transfer via a secure
connection but then there's also the
fact that you should use as secure jaat
implementations so the library that I
was actually using is Jason web token
but I was using an old version of it and
the old version has two drawbacks it
doesn't allow you to whitelist
algorithms meaning specifying Oh
only the algorithms that should be
supported in this case I really just
want to support HS 256 and then good
implementations also have this fallback
where if you're trying to verify a job
that has no signature and you're trying
to verify it with a like with a secret
then this should fail like if the secret
isn't null this should always fail so if
you're if you're up to date with your
dependencies here you'll be able to have
not even that's Equifax and instead have
like a secure implementation if you're
not familiar with the accurate fact
story you should look that up but
basically that was a massive hack that
happened in the u.s. purely because the
company wasn't up to date with their
with their software and there was a
known vulnerability around this cool so
I said this is a social network so how
busy let me fix this because it's
getting really warm under this so
obviously you're able to post things on
this so if we go back here I said this
is markdown so we can do things like
hello Jess I'm con are you and we can
post this all this does is again it does
an HTTP POST request here with some form
data in the bottom with the actual
message and then we use the auth token
to verify that like on which user's
behalf we should post this now the
problem with that is that this can be
used by attackers to perform so-called
cross-site request forgery since we're
using cookies the browser sort of overly
eager to see hey they're like I have
cookies for this page so I'll just
submit them you know like I will just
send them with every form request even
if they're on a different domain so that
the basically an attacker can
impersonate you by just kind of getting
you to if you're logged in on a page
already to go to a website and then they
can do things on your behalf so the
first thing that happened was when I
went to this page this is a target blank
link so just a normal link that should
open in a new window
the problem with target blank links is
that the new page has access to the
opening page by using window dot opener
and window dot opener has a location
property and that works just like the
location property that you would use
your normal window meaning you can
redirect page requests you can redirect
the original page to anything else and
that's what an attacker could use then
in our case we just navigated it to like
a harmless page but this could be a
phishing page as well and users would
likely not detect that so in the case of
something like Facebook if you would
post a post a link there and they would
use target blank links the new page
could then do window that opener and
have redirect you to something that
looks like Facebook and most users would
not detect this unless they see it in
the URL bar unfortunately there's a way
to protect yourself against that there's
actually yeah there's two properties
that you should add under the rel
attribute which is no opener and no
refers oh no opener make sure in most
browsers to just not give the new page
access to window not opener and then no
refer will make sure that on the
browsers that don't support no opener
that you will actually not have access
to the refer link to protect yourself
from cross-site request forgeries or sea
surface acts this is fairly
straightforward as well it's a bit more
work because what we need to do is when
we get the page that you want to do the
like submission later on we need to
generate a C surf token so that's just a
unique token for the user that we will
set on the one hand as a cookie in our
case underscore C surf and then we will
also submit that as on the page
somewhere as for example a hidden input
field and then when the when we do the
actual post requests instead of just
submitting the cookie we will also
manually submit this value either as a
header or we will submit it as a request
body or query parameter and the reason
why this actually protects you from
these sort of attacks is that the
attacker would be able to kind of
leverage the fact that the browser sends
these cookies automatically but there's
no way for the user to read the attacker
to read the cookie because that's
blocked by only being accessible from
your own domain so that's why this
protection works now let's talk about
little Bobbie tables younger brother the
cross-site scripting attack
if you're not familiar with little Bobby
tables it originates from an xkcd comic
where family of hackers named their kid
like a sequel injection and the director
of the school is sort of mad because it
dropped all the student records because
they weren't sanitizing their inputs and
if we talk about cross-site scripting
this is one of the most famous
cross-site scripting attacks does anyone
have an idea what this source code is
from so if I haven't seen anyone who
guessed this all right so this is from a
famous attack called the myspace war
more Sammy worm or JC JC or worm and
that was a cross-site scripting attack
from 2005 performed by a person called
Sammy and what this would do is if he
posted this on his page and I would send
friend requests to everyone who visited
his page and then post that on their
page and then send friend requests to
them that's also how they caught him
because Sammy had overnight several
million friends on MySpace
which is a slight indicator that there
he did something and the thing with the
reason why this is interesting is that
myspace actually had access s protection
but Sammy was able to circumvent this
XSS protection and two of the tricks
that I personally found interesting were
these two so there wasn't any
possibility to use inline script tags so
Sammy couldn't use that however what
they allow was to use CSS so he created
a div tag and used CSS and specify the
background URL to then have a JavaScript
protocol in there that let him write
JavaScript they disabled though to use
quotes in there so what he had to do is
he had to basically eval another
attribute that he would pick out of the
Dom in this case it was just the same
diff tag and then eval that code where
you could write the code the other thing
is they blocked certain keywords such as
inner HTML or onreadystatechange which
is used on Ajax requests if you are not
using something like jQuery or if you're
not using something like fetch these
days which wasn't around at that time
however he circumvented
by basically turning those words into
strings chopping them in the middle
recon catenae ting them and then
availing that because no regular
expression was able to catch that and he
used a bunch of other tricks as well if
you want to figure if you want to read
about them you should check out that
blog post but the bottom line here is
that it's really hard serve to block XSS
and now you might say well I could just
block eval right but javascript is this
beautiful language that allows you to
write JavaScript code in a million ways
so all of these to eval and those are
not the only four solutions like we can
do way more marching clapper he is
actually from Hamburg he did a great
talk and just come Iceland about how you
grow JavaScript in Hebrew and in sort of
all sorts of other languages including
languages from the Star Wars universe
sort of like you can write this and any
kind of character set so you should
really just not trust that you can just
block things by regular expression so
bottom line is blocking XSS is not
trivial and in fact I have a
vulnerability on here as well so if we
go here the library that I'm using to
convert the markdown to HTML is called
marked it's one of the most popular
libraries on NPM for to do that and the
version that I'm using is not the latest
but the second to latest or something
and that one actually has a
vulnerability so by default it has a
sanitize function so things like alert
hello won't work but let's just be sure
so this doesn't work it's being escaped
now that we can use a similar trick -
Sammis and use the javascript protocol
here and we're just going to create a
link here so that's how you create a
link and markdown and we're going to try
to do alert one here I'm going to copy
this and this is being escaped as well
because the library is smart enough to
detect that that's essentially just
writing inline JavaScript now this is
where it becomes fun I'm just going to
make this a bit bigger I'm not sure how
familiar you are with character
encodings but you can express a closing
prayer and
Jesus as an percent hash 41 semicolon
that's literally the same character and
if you look up your ASCII table colin is
ampersand hash 58 semicolon and we post
this we'll see you that's already a
difference right there is no closing
parenthesis here anymore
there's just no text so we're getting
somewhere
but it's still smart enough to figure
out that like hey ampersand hash 58
that's a semi that's a call in so I'm
just gonna block this however if we add
this small word this the best word than
JavaScript because we never know what it
is the story looks a bit different
because suddenly the link appeared and
what happens here and if we click this
we'll see that it actually works the
reason why this works is that the
browser tries to be helpful and the
browser sees oh yeah you're using
ampersand hash 58 I don't see a
semicolon but I think that's just a typo
so I'll just insert that for you and
then everything afterwards turns valid
JavaScript so that's why I use this in
this case because it's a valid
JavaScript I thought would write some
other things that would fail and
wouldn't execute the next slide but
because it's valid JavaScript this just
works shoutout to guy from sneek who
actually showed this to me they were
also the ones who fixed this in this
library unfortunately there's still a
vulnerability in this library around
data your eyes but it's a bit harder to
demonstrate so I decided to show this
one but the bottom line here is really
that encoding can be really dangerous
and there are a million ways to express
the same code so just never trust user
input be skeptical as you can also don't
trust CSS because CSS can be dangerous
as well Jake Archibald recently
published a nice blog post about this
kind of showing how you should just not
trust third-party CSS because there are
a bunch of things you can do about this
as well there it's that's just an talk
by itself all right let's talk about
Jason P so Jason P if you're not
familiar with that has especially been
used in the past to circumvent same
origin policy so that's the idea of
loading data asynchronously on your page
from from a separate domain and that's
by default blocked with Ajax requests
but there's a way to kind of like
circumvent that and the idea there is
you create a global function and then
you insert dynamically a script tag in
our case we just placed it in there and
this is a JSONP enabled endpoint meaning
it gets some query parameter with a
callback name and what it will do is
instead of returning the plain jason it
will wrap the json into a into a
function call so that basically this is
being triggered as a callback function
now this by itself is harmless unless
you crapoly implement it and that means
that you're not verifying what you're
passing in here is a callback and if we
have that and we have a cross-site
scripting vulnerability this is where
the fun part starts so for whatever
reason I was logged out again so and
again so how many of you are familiar
with service workers all right so if
you're not familiar with service workers
there and network proxy that you can
install meaning it can intercept network
requests and sort of is often being used
to create offline available apps so you
can cache things manually and you can
control the cache now this is a very
powerful feature and that's why the
browser's only allow you to install it
from your own domain now so that an
attacker can install one now if you have
a JSONP implementation that is
vulnerable meaning it doesn't verify
what you're passing and as a callback
you have a page on your own domain that
allows you to generate any JavaScript
and that's what I'm doing here so if I
install this if I post this and we click
this link we will see first nothing but
then I refresh the page and I can
refresh this as often as possible but
I'm only seeing this hacked because what
happened and actually that's where I
need the dev tools but let's see if we
can how they're working again I have no
clue what's happening here so we can see
that it installed a serviceworker and we
can see that this is a very long URL for
Service Worker because what I'm doing is
in the callback I'm specifying the
entire source code of this Service
Worker so we click here that's the
entire code basically it's a bunch of
codes ending with a slash slash to kind
of comment out the entire code mainly
because we don't care about it like the
entire payload but we could also just
keep that going now in here all we do is
we say that like hey any request that
isn't to port 4000 we just override it
with an h1 hacked and some other code
now this is a very obvious one to pull
off with this what you would typically
see an attacker do in this situation
would be to insert a script tag secretly
without you ever noticing it because it
doesn't it they don't have to overwrite
the entire request response they can
just insert something and then keep it
going so you would never notice this
like you if this is installed it's
really hard to detect unless someone
actually reads the source code of the
Service Worker they have installed which
at least I don't do for other websites
I'm not sure if that's something you do
as a hobby but if we unregister this and
refresh the page it works again except
that like you don't see it so I'm gonna
close them there we go there we go so
now you know the page works again cool
so luckily there's a for a lot of these
vulnerabilities there's a sort of hero
in town that can protect you called
content security policy and what this
does is it allows you to specify a set
of rules that the browser should play by
with respect to your resources so if we
go to this page which all it the only
difference it does is it applies ESP on
this so the first thing we see is that
down here there used to be images but
there they disappeared and if we click
here that doesn't work anymore and this
doesn't work either so if we look here
and we go into the console pane we see a
bunch of red messages and all of them
have go in the same direction of saying
hey all of these blocks violate the
content security policy or CSP so
look like it's essentially just an HTTP
header that defines these rules to play
by so in my case the CSP says hey the
default source that we allow is anything
from my own domain however for scripts
and styles I only want to allow things
that use a certain ons so that's
something that changes on every request
so attackers can't hard code this
meaning only things that you on request
are convinced that should be there can
be there
I completely block objects because I
don't see any use case for flash on my
page in fact I don't see a use case for
flash on any page but feel free to
convince me of other things for images I
only allow things that are hosts on my
own domain or if I'm API dot adorable
i/o which I use for these adorable icons
here some of them are adorable some of
them are sort of weird and that's why
for example the Twitter images didn't
work that were further down on the page
I block all fonts or I block all fonts
that are not on my own domain or on
google fonts and I block all mixed
content meaning no HTTP content on the
page as well as a report your I which is
where it would report any kind of like
failed request so if we go to my
terminal we can see we can see all these
requests being made here kind of like
giving you information about hey what
was violated there's a way to run this
in report only mode as well so if you're
trying to gradually move over to that
you can say that like hey just report
don't actually block the resources which
is a good way to kind of like detect
during development and stuff like that
like hey which is like what are actually
things that are being blocked by this
and are we destroying the functionality
or something
CSP though shouldn't be your like
security policy like you shouldn't just
rely on that and be like yep nothing can
happen to me now it should just be a
safety net because writing really good
CSP is hard so if you're relying on that
there was a paper of Google where they
have looked at CSP policies on famous
website and a lot of them were
completely insufficient so you shouldn't
rely on that as like as a security
policy always kind of think of all the
other vulnerabilities I showed you and
try to fix them just have this as a
safety net that in case you screwed up
something or a dependency screwed up
something that you're you're a bit safer
other things you should look out for are
things like click tracking meaning you
shouldn't allow two iframe your page
unless you really have a use case for
that and most pages don't so you can use
that but I'll do that by an HTTP header
they can either be deny or self self
would allow you still to do it on your
own page then I would just completely
block it you should check out a library
libraries like helmet which is a library
for Express that set certain HTTP
headers on your request that are just
good practices for security one of them
is disallowing the I framing don't show
versions of fronted libraries and your
server that's really important because
that's like helping the attackers to
like know exactly what they need to do
because if they know you're using react
versions 16-point whole point - then
they know all right those are the
vulnerabilities I should go for and same
goes for the server if they know your
expressed you're using an express server
they already know that like those are
the things I want to try uncheck for
types of input so if you're expecting
for somewhere parameter to be a string
check that it's really a string because
some libraries try to be nice to you and
parse things as objects if they see
that's a JSON for example with numbers
and especially with objects this can be
really dangerous because if you're
trying to do like no sequel database
lookup for example in MongoDB for like
the password being being a string and I
pass in an object I can do a no sequel
injection and have login as any user
through that other things consider
security audits
security is hard so contact someone who
is a security expert if you have someone
on your team that's great if you don't
hire someone externally because it's a
good investment you don't want to be
thinking about this only when you go
hacked because at that point it gets
really expensive stay up to date with
versions because their dependencies can
introduce a bunch of vulnerabilities
that you just never think of greenkeeper
is a great tool for that and use tools
to detect security vulnerabilities in
your dependencies so NSP or sneak are
great for that sneak in fact even
patches security vulnerabilities for you
like the data URI one and marked is
actually patched if you use sneak even
though it's not patched in the actual
library to wrap this up use HTTP only
cookies if there's no reason for them to
be available in JavaScript be skeptical
of JW TS just don't treat them as a
single source of truth and have like an
up-to-date library use no opener and no
refer on your target blank links UC surf
tokens whenever you have rely on like
cookies for example has an
authentication method blocking XSS isn't
trivial because encoding can be really
dangerous so just don't don't think
you've got that covered
always be skeptical and try to do
different things to kind of circumvent
that be careful of JSONP a callback
should never contain anything that isn't
a word character and here we never even
like a number because we could start
encoding things so just have only word
characters in there UCSB as a safety net
because it's really helpful and most
importantly stay up to date because if
your dependencies have vulnerabilities
you can have the most secure code on
your site you will still be vulnerable
I'll publish those slides after this
talk on this URL and I'll tweet about it
as well so you can take a look the
entire application that I showed you
including documentation resources to
security matters on this URL again I'm
going to tweet this and I have stickers
but both of these so if you find me
later I can give you some of those if
you're a sticker obsessed like I am and
with that thank you everyone for your
attention I'll be around for the rest of
the day if you have any questions
[Applause]
[Music]